so we are very close to the glacier you
can see those floating these are ice
beautiful
[Music]
they keep seeing ice fall into the into
here
anyway here we go look at that very
close very close
[Music]
we're gonna sit here on our balcony yeah
some hot chocolate and enjoy the ice
in Alaska
[Music]
[Applause]
today is the brand new day of day
four right yeah day four okay today is
day four that sounds like a lucky day
today is day at Sea cruising but we're
gonna see glaciers and I've been uh I've
been taking on a non-non seasick Vibe
you know tradition has been getting
pretty seasick on cruises but this
Cruise have been now I'm not seasick and
so far okay
let's go get coffee I need coffee maybe
just stop saying they're working when
you say the word made me too I want to
say what word
she's sick no see what see peace whereas
I'm having seat peas today see peace it
looks good coffee why are we filming
before coffee
[Music]
oh wow oh wow Evan what did you allow
for oh
why is there a camera on my face all the
time to kind of enjoy my big nut
um there's a cappuccino but it's very
good the Palm is really well done
not just like all phone but hmm
yeah good how was your breakfast
uh good
feeling good uh I don't know I maybe
have a metal five right now how was your
breakfast it was it was okay yeah
I didn't eat that much oh this is great
okay what are we doing we're going we're
going to figure out our restaurant
reservations yeah then we're gonna go to
uh
well eventually do some line dancing and
then maybe some Pilates and stretching
and dancing and waiting for the glaciers
so we can take some really good pictures
pictures and do some hot chocolate on
the balcony under a blanket watching the
glaciers go by
[Music]
tell me where are we going
we're going to watch the lecture of what
we're gonna see on this trip because
Nina loves lectures no that's history
and we're probably going to be very bad
students in the back chatting with each
other tickling each other telling little
sweet nothings and jokes to each other
but who knows there might be something
interesting that we learned if you learn
one thing's in a lecture it was worth it
[Music]
working at the cafe strategizing yeah
yeah yeah I think the toll like hold
almost two hours we just work and then
just five minutes before Oh Evan's like
oh we need to go we need to go yeah
lunch because this place is hard to get
in
[Music]
how's the food yeah man
tissue is fresh
Heaven did you enjoy the lunch
pretty good yeah what's the best about
the lunch being with Nina
it's a Sashimi Sami Sushi is probably my
favorite yeah
uh this was okay a little slow as more
people came yeah so we're gonna we're
gonna what we're gonna head to the
buffets if they're anything different
uh because they're rolls they give you
like two pieces of the Roll so you have
to anyway it takes a while so and then
we check outside because I think we're
by the glaciers we might have some good
views
[Music]
thumbs up
so that was fun yeah that was done I
almost fell down the step don't fall
down the steps okay but you're so tall
you know okay he met a fan yeah well we
both made a thing Jeffrey yeah the
channel yeah he made he made me a
special drink the Jeffrey special Bahama
Mama you liked it
has lots of ingredients okay what's the
next Evan uh back to the room we're
gonna get the glacier soon so we get to
see that from the out from the cabin the
cabin yeah
[Music]
uh yeah that's the next main thing and
then potentially some Pilates and uh
Sunset stretching
so we are very close to the glacier you
can see those floating these are eyes
beautiful
[Music]
did you hear it oh yeah can you hear I
don't know if the video can hear this
something
over here look at this beautiful what do
you want to say
enjoyed our vacation you want them to
enjoy our vacation yeah but we will
enjoy that we will enjoy the vacation I
am
we keep seeing ice fall into the into
here
but anyway here we are look at that very
close very close
foreign
it's so bright it's so cool though that
was cool I mean I ran into get some
quick makeup done no you didn't even get
a makeup done what did you do what did
you run in to do I was trying to put a
makeup on but then I just put the cream
and that's it cream cream yeah you're
always beautiful so we took some good
pictures and now we're gonna get some
hot chocolate sit on the balcony as uh
we head to wherever our next point is
but that was pretty cool
Evan just poured himself a hot chocolate
yeah
try it try it yeah no you oh just try it
the audience want to see oh yeah oh it's
pretty rich yeah yeah we're gonna sit
here on our balcony yeah some hot
chocolate and enjoy the ice
in Alaska
[Music]
and then how was your day been I was
like David yeah
yeah what did you do oh you're filming
me I just
I just uh wait didn't we film it we went
to the we chill hot water hot chocolate
hot chocolate but they saw that yeah
yeah Nina's happy yeah nice and clean
clean yeah and now we're gonna see if we
can go dancing okay yeah how was your
day going
good just lie down and chill
[Music]
you're very excited with your dish
try it try the cheese and tomato
we were at the French place last night
it was all the soft cheese now we get
the real cheese guys
the parmesan
yeah
[Music]
we just finished our dinner that took us
over two hours to eat oh my God I'm so
foreign
place because he didn't want he wasn't
hungry and then we ate like 10 quarts of
the meal it's a lot of food I love
anyways I I need to move I need to move
we're gonna we're gonna work it off yeah
what are we going to do to work it off
Evan I don't know walk around the boat
okay and then uh maybe Evan will do some
solo dancing solo Dancing Yeah that's
not very nice
looks like we have a special surprise
here Evan special surprise yeah we have
a box
Okay evan you want to open that see
what's in here you can open it with my
hand
foot
here we go
birdies yeah it's chocolate the last
thing the last thing I want right now is
more chocolate oh my gosh actually no we
didn't have that much chocolate
crafted by our chocolatiers and hand
packed by Ruby
it's made with sustainable cocoa
oh yeah that looks good
this one and this one this one maybe
that has caramel inside do they have
like okay holy cow
[Music]
okay just save it yeah put it in the
fridge thank you guys
[Music]
it has three sons two no three three
yeah two no three two ready yeah just
two however I remember three what what
were they
there was one Cha-Cha and one other song
and that's it really yep okay wow we
dance we danced now we need to walk
around more to burn off the food that we
ate yeah yeah it's cool I need to hold
on you gotta hold on okay yeah hold on
hold on for Life yeah we're gonna work
burn off some calories burn burn
[Music]
good morning Evan Carmichael
today we get into Juno yep you excited I
am what are we gonna do in Juno uh hike
yeah
crab eat crap yeah crap
king crab
and then uh do a tour oh I think we're
gonna see Wales I don't remember it's on
my list two hours hiking and then tour
to see the the whale okay what else do
you want to say I want to say
I love leaving the Carmichael
so we have half an hour
before we dock look at this view this is
we're having breakfast it's pretty cool
yeah it's pretty so we have hot number
before we talk but we're gonna grab some
breakfast before we get in look behind
you they just you know
it's Juno it's pretty
Evan is super excited
but he was he was dancing uh in the
cabin tonight tonight at this morning
and then they're watching videos about
what to do and you know what we should
have yeah super exciting yep yes
yeah that's how we roll
[Music]
to get off the boat
foreign
we're gonna eat later
because Evan looked it up everyone
recommended this place
what's the best wish you have here you
get the buckets of king crab yeah pricey
three pounds is 200 bucks six pounds is
400 bucks wow we recommend one pound per
person so we're basically in the
doesn't look like it
so
yeah I mean you got to go for the bucket
that's what that's what people come for
so okay we're in for a king crab lunch
after a hike yeah
Evan you ready for this hike I pick hike
two hours right yeah I'm ready yeah I'm
gonna see we're gonna wrestle bears at
the top I'm ready
[Music]
these are the Sockeye Salmons
yeah swimming Upstream yeah Emma's ready
to catch them I don't know about that
and make dinner tonight wow is that
what's happening yeah I don't know about
that
[Music]
this is what we're here for
and I see Evan Carmichael
okay
next up is Tracy's King Crab Shack yeah
you know what you're ordering Evan yeah
okay why don't you get lined up another
okay okay
Nina's getting her set up this is our
bucket of crap this thing was
a hundred dollars okay he's getting the
place mats
it's hard to set up okay can you hold it
you wanted me to film so yeah
right okay all right back we're gonna
have some
crab legs and butter and bread this is
the must do
thing here so
that's it
let's go Nina
I think your first bite wow that's a lot
of crap
bigger than my face
your first little bite of meat and see
what happens
he just Dives in huh no butter or
anything
fresh is it the best Alaskan king crab
you've ever had
[Music]
all right
here we go so they give you these tools
to cut open the crap and Nina just dive
them and uses their teeth with my teeth
what tools don't need tools see let's
get in there oh yeah meat comes out
good job we just finished our Keem crack
lunch king crab yeah lunch
do you like it pretty good
but Nina wasn't so happy so it's it's
dry and they get cold at the end not
even halfway through yeah not even
halfway till it gets cold became really
for Nina yeah so if she's not happy then
I'm definitely not happy
the next famous place is fish tacos fish
tacos
yeah
little spot here so we're going
[Music]
okay Nina's gonna dive in on the
legendary fish tacos what are you going
for Nina
spicy one in the middle yeah but the
they're in the middle one
how the hell of it yeah that's halibut
halibut here she goes it's good I hope
so
There She Goes
hot
yeah better than the crab yes okay good
are you happy she's happy happy wife is
a happy husband
and then we saw this Alaskan Craig
Escape here and it has pretty good
review so we picked up a s'more Nutella
crate and then two coffee to eat
try your Nutella s'more marshmallows
melting
mine this is for us oh yeah in a cold
City you need something warm
yeah
yeah warm keep eating before it gets too
cold
how do you feel Evan bum we got tacos we
got Crepes we got coffee
yeah good coffee yeah I actually love
the the tacos more more than what the
crabs oh yeah okay
yeah we're gonna go back to the cruise
just to use the bathroom and then we
have to head out again for our next
excursions
[Music]
we went back to the cruise
use the bathroom break
and then now we're going out again
we are watching and culinary experience
are you hungry no no very full taco
[Music]
we got out of a boat and then we're
going to another boat Evan
yeah but this one we can see whales from
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
did you have fun yeah yeah what's the
highlight
oh you filming what's the Highlight yeah
watching whales with Nina
and did I get a picture of you where you
slept yeah I did yeah I'm collecting
pictures of Nina with me while she
sleeps she's passed out on the bus and I
got I take a picture I think I'm at like
six right now I want to get 10. so we're
closing it no the whales are cool okay
those were poor I'm super full so I
think we're gonna skip dinner yeah and
go relax yeah and that was that was Juno
that was a very very long full day very
full day very full day tomorrow we're
doing the Epic
uh very
dangerous looking train ride that I'm
super excited for and if you want to see
us do it go check the video right there
we'll see you there believe